Now let's talk about our guest author.
Uh,
so we have bonding Rockman.
She's a graduate of the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
She's a Seattle local currently and an award winning health and science writer.
Her,
uh,
her work has appeared in Time magazine,
time.com.
Oh,
that's the Oprah magazine,
parenting babble,
double x linked cookie and the news and observer.
Uh,
she's here today to talk about her first book,
which came out one week ago.
I,
it's the gene machine.
How did,
uh,
how genetic technologies are transforming parenting and reshaping our society.
And in this book she explores the cutting edge of gene technology and how it is
transforming medicine,
bioethics,
healthcare,
and the factors that shape our families.
So let's welcome Miss Bonnie Roseman.
I Rock,
man.
Hi everyone.
Thanks so much for having me.
Um,
I want to let you know if you're worrying,
oh,
this doesn't really have that much to do with my,
my particular line of work.
Yes,
it does.
At its heart,
this is really a story about data and I know that,
that,
um,
that speaks to you.
So I'm going to start by telling you how this book came about,
which requires me to pull up this question about graduation texts or from 1994
when I graduated from UNC,
it was the bicentennial UNC happens to be the nation's oldest public university.
And we were fully expecting a really impressive speaker.
So other classes had gotten Madeline Albright,
Desmond Tutu,
John Grisham,
and uh,
we heard we were,
we were,
uh,
we were getting a guy named Francis Collins at no one knew who he was at the
time.
Mother,
I see.
Not there at the time.
He was director of the National Human Genome Research Institute.
What,
no one knew what that was either.
So he,
his job was to try to articulate all 3 billion base pairs that are part of our
genome,
our genetic code.
And it has,
I have to say it seemed incredibly remote.
Uh,
nevertheless,
Francis did a bang up job.
He gave a great speech.
We all went out into the world and in,
he did such a good job that in 2009,
15 years after graduation,
he was actually appointed head of the National Institutes of health or NIH,
which is our country's medical research agency.
Um,
that was the same year that I,
um,
started working at Time magazine and a,
I was a health and parenting columnist.
This was my column.
It was called family matters and I could write about pretty much anything I
wanted as long as it intersected with health and parenting.
So that means I got the write about Beyonce and her promotion of public
breastfeeding and how friends influence other friends decision to vaccinate or
not to vaccinate their children.
Um,
and I have found that left to my own devices,
I actually wrote quite a bit about genetics.
So I wrote about some pretty questionable,
uh,
companies that were marketing tests to kind of determine the,
um,
your child's aptitude for a particular sport.
You know,
kind of depend based on their genes,
what they would be particularly good at if you want to sort of steer them in a
direction of a particular sport.
And I wrote about parents' decisions to share or not to share their genetic
testing results with um,
with their children.
And I had been doing this job for about six months when this study up there,
um,
landed in my inbox and I remember,
I remember this very well because I was on a plane with my family on route to a
family vacation and my kids who are three,
six,
and eight at the time,
I remember looking over at them,
they were all seated in one row and thinking,
what I want to know this level of data,
this depth of information about my kids.
So what this study was about,
the level of the information that this study was looking to,
to find out how to do with a group of parents who had had genetic testing and
the parents were then asked hypothetically if they would want to test their kids
under the age of 18 for some very common adult onset disorders,
things like diabetes,
like skin cancer and like high cholesterol or high blood pressure.
And the parents pretty much uniformly across the board said,
yeah,
totally bring it on.
We're going to,
this is going to be amazing.
We're going to get the clean bill of health,
are going to feel like our kids are super healthy and we'll move on.
So what they didn't realize was that these myths,
these mutations are so common that on average each kid would have about nine.
Now,
not to say there would definitely get the disease,
but they would,
they were at increased risk for developing this disease,
uh,
later on.
So what was striking to me is that people did not understand the connection
between genes,
heredity,
disease,
increased risks,
that they were doing this testing because they thought they were just roll
things out and feel really good.
And instead what they were going to do is find information that was not
particularly definitive but kind of raised more questions and in some cases
could actually raise more anxiety.
So that made me realize that genes are not black and white.
That in some cases their suggestions about what will happen down the road and in
some cases their certainty.
But it's really,
it's not very cut and dried.
And so there's this misconception really the genes are destiny,
but in truth,
it's really just part of the puzzle.
So I was so interested in these findings that genes are not always destiny,
that you really can't know that I decided to look into it more.
So this multidimensional aspect of DNA and genes of heredity,
um,
led me to pitch a story to my editor at time about the implications of
sequencing children's genomes or reading their entire genetic code.
And I'm about getting all this data,
all this,
these huge quantities of information about your kids,
some of which will be,
um,
deterministic,
others,
you know,
at some of the information what really we won't even really know what it means.
And is that a good idea?
So,
um,
it ended up being a series of weeklong online series and then that morphed into
a cover story,
the last cover story of 2012 which you see up on the screen.
And you know,
when you spend a ton of time on a big project,
you're either,
you never want to hear another word about it or you're even more intrigued.
So for me,
it was the ladder and I decided to go ahead and write a book about this world in
which we have more access than ever to cutting edge technology to peer inside
our genomes and,
and to emerge with the snapshot of disease,
both potential and actual.
And I wanted to do this by telling the stories of real people.
So speaking of stories of real people you may know,
recognize this guy up there on the screen.
So,
uh,
several years ago,
um,
Sergei Brin did a 23 and me gene panel and he learned that he has got a pretty
rare genetic mutation that predisposes him to develop Parkinson's.
Um,
so I looked up his blog from when he got his test results and he says that,
um,
that when he had done the genetic testing,
he quote viewed it mostly as entertainment.
And yet what happened is he ended up finding this gene mutation that actually
means he has a significantly elevated risk of developing Parkinson's disease.
Now,
some people in his situation might feel very freaked out about that depending on
how,
what their impressions are and what their relationship is with data,
especially personal genetic data.
But Sergei,
on the other hand that he said this in his,
um,
in his blog,
he said,
I feel fortunate to be in this position until the fountain of Youth.
It's discovered all of us will have some conditions in our old age only.
We don't know what they will be.
I have a better guest than almost anyone else for what ILS may maybe mine and
have decades to prepare for it.
So that is,
that made me think back to that study that I,
you know,
originally set me off on this entire journey and it's really interesting what
he's,
what Sergei says because he is then he actually goes on in his blog to give
specific examples of how he might change his life due to learning about this
genetic mutation and the predisposition to Parkinson's.
So there's some research showing that exercise may be protective against the
development of Parkinson's.
So I can only imagine that he has the common gym rat.
He can also direct his money to help support research into causes of Parkinson's
treatments for Parkinson's.
So I think that his experience is really illustrative of how genetic data,
even if it is not a certainty,
really allows you to take control of your life.
This is Gracie,
she has down syndrome.
I'll tell you a little bit more about Gracie and a second.
Um,
one way that all this access to new genetic technology and data is really
changing our world is that it's redefining the holy grail concept of what it
means to be or to have a healthy baby.
So when you get pregnant,
um,
oftentimes if you ask people,
oh,
you haven't a girl or a boy though,
they will sometimes,
sometimes they have a preference,
but sometimes they'll just say,
I don't care.
I just want a healthy baby.
So what exactly is a healthy baby?
We have this constantly expanding array of genetic technologies that offer
insight prenatally into a baby's health.
But what does it mean to be healthy?
For example,
a child,
a baby born with down syndrome,
about half of the time they have heart defects that need surgical repair,
but about half of the time they don't and they can just go home from the
hospital.
So is a baby with down syndrome,
a healthy baby up for debate j.
So,
you know,
when I was born,
my mom didn't know if I had down syndrome,
shouldn't even know what gender I was.
And today already in the first trimester,
there are blood tests that can detect down syndrome,
um,
in a noninvasive way,
which is really reshaping a lot of the debate around,
um,
around disability and the perception of who should and should not be born in our
society.
So back to Gracie.
She is,
um,
she's in Boston.
You lives in Boston,
right outside and uh,
she likes lipsync into Taylor swift.
I visited her,
uh,
two years ago and she,
um,
Lipsync Macklemore's thrift shop for me.
She is funny.
She is a diligent learner.
She is doing really well in school,
thanks to her mom's advocacies.
So she's an inclusion classes and she's also really charmingly irreverent.
One of the funniest stories in the book is Gracie's mom telling me about
Gracie's trip to the dentist.
So I'm Gracie.
The dentist was trying to butter her up and said to Gracie,
oh,
you're so cute.
Can you open your mouth for me?
And Gracie responded,
get away from me.
You word that rhymes with witch.
A friend of Gracie's mom joke.
The Gracie was really just saying what everyone else is thinking.
Anyway.
Um,
since there is now new research to improve the lives of people who have down
syndrome,
there's research and to silencing the extra copy,
the extra copy of the 21st chromosome that characterizes this condition.
There's research into drugs that can be taken prenatally by a pregnant mom or
drugs that can be taken after birth by a child with down syndrome.
And as you might imagine,
some parents are really excited about this and some parents are super
conflicted.
And for from Melanie Gracie's mom,
you know,
like any parent,
how many of you have kids?
Okay,
so,
and even for those of you who don't have kids,
you can imagine,
think back to your parents.
Everyone always wants the best for their child.
They want their child to have every single opportunity.
Yet that really raises the question of what does it mean to have every
opportunity,
our drugs actually changing the essence of the child versus helping them to
achieve their potential.
So let's do a quick poll.
I'm going to ask you if it's good,
bad,
or in consequential to have a baby who's born blind or missing a lamb or with
some sort of intellectual disability.
Um,
raise your hand if you think that's a good thing.
What about that
in consequential doesn't matter at all.
So that's,
that's pretty standard.
I've never had anyone say it's a good thing.
I'm most people.
Um,
most people say it's a bad thing and usually a couple of people say it's
inconsequential.
It doesn't really matter one way or aren't they or another.
And I interview a professor of law in the book who,
who he researches Eugenics,
which is the,
um,
the practice of trying to build a superior race and that is now out of favor in
this country.
It reached its height during the Nazi era.
Um,
but it did go on in the United States for many,
many,
many years.
And this professor Paul Lombardo,
he posited that if he would do a survey of most people whom he consider
considers compassionate and not mean spirited,
that most people would say there are actually some conditions the baby should
not be born with.
If there is a way to avoid it.
I found that really powerful because you know,
we as a society in general,
we think that we are open minded,
open hearted,
and yet when it comes right down to it,
if you're asked about disability and you have the option to,
uh,
to opt out of it,
most people,
most people say no thanks in that sort of situation.
So I spoke with a mom who's son has something called 22 Q deletion,
which is,
um,
which is a condition in which her son is missing the small part of his 22nd
chromosome.
And it's accompanied by,
you know,
mild to moderate intellectual disability.
There can be heart defects.
So this boy in particular was doing amazingly well when I interviewed his mom,
he was in a four year university.
He was living three hours away from home and still this mom was terrified of the
possibility that her son would give birth to a child like him.
So every year when her son,
who was I think around 20 at the time,
would go for a checkup with his geneticist.
This mom would besiege the geneticists to say,
you have to tell him that he has to use birth control.
So here you have this mom who loves her son and who's really proud of his
accomplishments and his achievements.
But she's saying,
oh my God,
don't have a kid like you.
So people were 22 Q have a 50% chance of passing that onto their children.
And this,
this mom is saying,
please don't,
don't give me a grandchild.
Like don't give me a grandchild like you.
Um,
so you can imagine what kind of delicate ethical,
tight rope that is too to be perched on.
You can actually avoid 22 Q by three,
something called preimplantation genetic diagnosis.
This is a picture up here of an embryo and a couple cells are being siphoned out
of the embryo.
The embryo is just a few days old,
probably about five days old.
And then those cells are analyzed to determine whether there is the presence or
absence of a particular genetic mutation.
And so the way that it is currently used right now is,
um,
it's,
it's employed in most cases to get rid of very severe,
often fatal childhood diseases,
something like taste the,
which is often fatal before a child would reach kindergarten.
So you take these embryos so you're not,
it's very different from something like gene editing and you probably have all
heard of something called Crispr,
which is a way to edit genes.
So this,
this is not editing genes.
Instead,
this is taking embryos,
looking at them and saying,
oh,
that one,
that one has,
that one has taste sacks.
Okay,
let's discard that.
Or let's throw that,
let's put that aside.
And this one doesn't have taste x,
let's implant that one into a woman's uterus.
So you are picking and choosing and you're,
you're selecting in favor of not having a particular disease.
So what's different,
again,
going back to,
um,
to Crispr,
CRISPR obviously raises concerns of what's,
you know,
in the media we talk about designer babies.
What does that really mean?
Well,
the truth is that we don't know currently how,
uh,
build a future Google engineer or manufacture the next Michael Jordan or the
next Yoyo Ma.
And the reason is because there is not one single gene that codes for a killer
jumpshot or amazing,
um,
amazing ability as a cellist or as a programmer.
Um,
it's a confluence of
influences from your environment,
where you live,
who your parents are,
your exposure to all sorts of things plus your genetic makeup.
So PGD,
um,
is often PGD.
Preimplantation genetic diagnosis is not as,
as you might imagine,
it is not as,
um,
as ethically fraught as something using CRISPR technology to edit genes to edit
embryos.
And it's been used for decades to avoid transmitting these serious diseases such
as taste acts that I mentioned,
but it's also now increasingly being considered for diseases that are not quite,
that are not necessarily fatal.
So,
so most people in this room probably know someone who's been diagnosed with
breast cancer and you can select an embryo that does not have a breast cancer
mutation.
So if that BRC one or be Mrca to mutation runs in your family or a whole host of
other breast cancer mutations,
Brc one and two are just the most common.
So if those run in your family and you want to kind of stop that train and say,
I don't want to transmit,
um,
you know,
this has been hell in my family.
My mom died,
my aunt died,
I was diagnosed when I was,
you know,
in my twenties and I don't want to pass this legacy onto my child.
You can do preimplantation genetic diagnosis to have a child who has not
inherited that.
Your,
your genetic mutation.
So that raises the question of is,
are we playing God by doing something like this?
You know,
breast cancer is very different from Tay-sachs.
Having a genetic mutation that predisposes you to breast cancer just means that
you're an increased risk for it.
It's like Sergei and his Parkinson's,
he won't necessarily get it.
It means he's at elevated risk for it.
So knowing that someone,
knowing that an embryo is an elevated risk for a disease,
is it ethical to not have that child?
To not bring that child into the world because of a possibility of a disease
that may develop decades down the road.
Now let's change the scenario even a little bit more.
Let's say you are completely opposed to doing something like that to using
preimplantation genetic diagnosis and that data to,
you know,
weed out certain embryos.
So,
but let's say you have a breast cancer mutation in your family and you have a
baby,
do you then think that you have the right to data to know whether your child has
inherited your genetic mutation?
So pediatric ethics guidelines say no you don't.
You don't have the right to know.
You don't have the right to test your child under the age of 18 unless it's
medically necessary.
And something like knowing about a risk for breast cancer would not be
considered medically necessary for us three months old.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to read to you a little bit from the book of even something like this,
how complicated it can be.
So the first,
um,
the first little bit I'm going to read to you is from a doctor named Mike bomb
shot.
He is the head of pediatric genetic medicine at Udab and he says,
we are recommending that parents be left with the ambiguity that their infant is
a higher risk for breast cancer because they have breast cancer in their family.
But we're unwilling to test the baby to know for sure he disagrees with that.
And he says,
if we're counseling someone in clinic and they're at high risk for breast cancer
and they have their infant daughter with them,
why in the world would we wait to talk again until she's 18?
Why would we not test and say she's not a BRC,
a carrier or she is.
And here's what you should do about it.
We should use this information,
this data to improve health care.
And one of the clearest ways to improve health care is to prevent disease.
It's very clear cut.
So I find that incredibly persuasive.
And then I'm going to read to you a passage from a woman who became my friend
after I interviewed her.
She was diagnosed with breast cancer at age 32.
Her mom died when,
um,
when she was very young and,
and she has a,
a BRC mutation.
So,
um,
this is Debbie.
Right after she found out via ultrasound that she was having a daughter,
I came out saying,
oh my God,
what if she gets breast cancer?
Her husband,
Evan,
did not understand.
He calls me doom and gloom,
but I said,
I'm going to die if she gets breast cancer.
Debbie was determined to find a way to test her daughter,
her daughter,
Jordan,
but her husband was adamantly opposed and now she agrees with him.
I don't think it's fair for us to have that information and have that heaviness
in our family or in how we relate to Jordan.
I think knowing whether Jordan is positive or negative would also cause a lot of
tension and sadness in our family.
When you think about testing a child,
you have to think of the ramifications that it would have on lots of family
members.
So you can see two very well reasoned,
yet extremely different perspectives on the value and the appropriateness of
information.
It's really super complicated.
As the technology evolves,
these,
um,
these ethical dilemmas are coming at us fast and furious.
I'm not a scientist.
I like to think of myself as a humanist and I wrote this book because I'm really
fascinated by these questions.
Have right or wrong and red lines are there red lines,
if there are red lines,
where are they?
Who Decides?
And nowhere is more heated than when it comes to making babies.
Again,
we have to just keep asking ourselves the question.
And as Google Earth,
I'm sure you can appreciate that this is there such a thing as too much
information.
So these are all really big ideas.
I don't give yes or no answers because I don't believe there are none.
Um,
I think these,
um,
decisions are all extremely personal.
They're individual and it really comes down to choice in what's right for you
and your comfort with a great degree of information and data.
So if you're sick of small talk at your next party,
you can try these topics on for size.
Do parents have a right to all of their child's health data?
So some experts believe that within a couple of years we're going to have our
genome in the cloud.
So if parents,
if that does come to pass,
should parents know everything there is to know about a child's DNA and let's
say that there's a problem.
Would you love your kid less or maybe even more?
Now back to that BRC mutation,
say your newborn hazard genome sequenced and a BRC mutation is discovered.
You know,
a couple of minutes ago I told you that,
well,
pediatric ethics guidelines say that we don't test,
we don't have kids under 18 for something that's not medically necessary and
needs to be dealt with right now by it.
It's really likely that that baby has inherited her genetic mutation from her
mom or her dad.
And let's say those parents don't know that they have the mutation.
So by telling them you then are enabling them to take whatever measures they
feel are appropriate.
Um,
a mom could have a prophylactic mastectomy,
a dad could get,
men obviously get breast cancer as well.
They're also at greater risk for prostate cancer.
So you're just basically enabling them to be more empowered regarding their own
health.
And you know,
it's really complicated because you think that you're not supposed to tell the
parents because you're sort of encroaching upon the child,
you know,
the child's right of privacy and protecting her own genetic data and yet telling
the Chai,
telling the parents that the child has a mutation could actually be a way,
a clear way to do something really amazing for that child by potentially a
burden the death of one of her parents.
So in short,
it used to be a lot easier to be pregnant.
Um,
as I said,
my mom did not even know if I was a boy or a girl when I was born.
And today we have tons and tons of genetic data.
Um,
we often,
I won't say often vet regularly at the test get,
get more and more sophisticated.
We'll find out information that is completely unclear.
Um,
and you have to then decide,
do you proceed with this pregnancy based on really uncertain information?
I spend the stories of several families who got really disconcerted information,
like their baby was missing,
missing a couple of genes or some DNA was duplicated.
And what exactly does that mean?
And how do you proceed with that?
In some of these cases of parents learned that they actually had the same
deletions or genetic duplications,
and then it's,
you know,
it's pretty mind blowing me.
You have to figure out how to process all of that.
So I'm going to end with,
um,
I'm an end with the best compliment that I received about this book,
which is going to entail me telling you a little bit about the book building
process and these,
um,
these impressive blurbs that if here on the back,
I feel like Vanna white up here.
Um,
so,
you know,
those blurbs don't just appear there.
It's not like someone goes into a bookstore,
reads my book,
and it's just so incredibly moved that they contact my publisher and say,
I've got to write some words of praise for the back of that lady's jacket.
Um,
no.
Instead,
it's this very arduous process of reaching out to,
um,
uh,
so I,
convened with my editor and we kind of developed a list of really influential
people who would be amazing to blurb the back of the book.
And then it's this very humiliating and process of reaching out via email and
basically begging these people who are already incredibly busy.
Two,
please read your book and if they're so inclined and if they like it,
maybe they'll write a couple pithy words for you to stick on the jacket.
So one of these women,
um,
Kelly Behnam French had just written her own book,
really beautiful memoir about the birth of her extremely premature daughter.
The book is called Juniper.
And I had,
uh,
she had agreed,
to receive a copy of the book.
And so I followed up for the first time on October 26,
um,
by writing,
to her and saying,
Hey,
just checking in,
you know,
trying to remain all casual.
And she responded,
just got the book and haven't looked at it yet,
but I'm looking forward to it.
So I wrote back,
Ugh,
isn't this blurb seeking just the worst?
I appreciate your making the effort,
Kelly.
And the next day she wrote back the whole book promotion thing.
Ugh.
Standing naked on the street corner would be more fun.
So I decided I was going to up the ante here,
more like standing naked on the street corner in Subzero temps in times square
that would only begin to capture the Har.
And she went radio silent on me after I bared my soul.
Um,
so I decided to check in and after a week,
hello fellow naked street corner dweller,
I'm gritting my teeth and oh so casually checking in to see if you just might be
inclined to blurb this book of mine.
Time dragged by.
There was no word.
And then finally I got an email from her 10 words total.
This book doesn't suck.
Thank God that would've been awkward.
I laughed and I wrote back to her,
that is the blurb right there.
This book doesn't suck.
And then she responded.
You can see we had a great email correspondence going.
Um,
and she really had the last word she wrote.
Really that's all any of us can ever hope for.
So I find that,
uh,
it wasn't just about my buck.
That's really a universal truth.
Um,
so I hope you enjoyed hearing about the book and I hope you find it interesting.
I hope it makes you think about things that you hadn't really considered before
about science and babies and how these two things intersect in ways both
marvelous and mysterious.
And thank you so much for coming.
I'm happy to take any questions.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I mean we can debate the ethics and have a lot of philosophical arguments,
but at the end,
either have technology will work or it won't.
Right.
So you know,
when,
when little Johnny goes to school,
if little Alice who had genetic modification is better than him and everything,
then when Johnny has a brother or sister,
if the parents can afford it,
they're going to do it.
Right.
Oh Wow.
I'm not speaking for Joe for Johnny's parents.
Bye.
The important thing to note is that currently we don't know how to make so
called designer babies.
In fact,
in the book I talk about,
well,
in some ways we're actually already creating designer babies.
If anyone here has had a child,
um,
via IVF,
or know someone who has and it's everywhere now,
um,
those could,
those babies could actually technically be considered designer babies.
So if you're choosing donor sperm,
you go through this entire checklist,
you can,
um,
learn,
where the donor or went to school at the donor's job is what the donor's
personality is like.
You can access baby pictures.
Um,
you know,
it's basically like this whole smorgasbord of,
um,
trays there.
You know,
the donor has a quick temper,
the donor has an amazing sense of humor and you can select all of these things,
but,
um,
you know,
so I think it can be argued that already were doing that.
And you know,
people who have,
um,
who go through assisted reproduction,
but if you're just having sex the regular way,
the way that we've done for centuries,
um,
we just don't,
you can't,
you know,
it's luck of the draw.
And even if you then apply technologies through assisted reproduction,
we don't know how to make the next Einstein.
So it's a whole,
you know,
it's kind of,
someone could crack the code then I think that your,
um,
I think your question would be a lot more valid.
But currently we don't know.
There's not one,
there's not the intelligence gene and the awesome on the football field,
you know,
Seattle Seahawks gene.
So it's just not,
it's not,
it's not possible at this point in time.
It's really focused more on disease and elimination of disease.
Well,
thank you very much for telling us about your book.
That doesn't suck.
Thank you.